watching today's impeachments spectacle
and listening to all the bluster and the
blather I came away with one overriding
thought as ineffective and pathetic the
Democrats are as legislators there are
even worse actors I solemnly and sadly
opened the debate on the impeachment
today is a solemn day in America a day
that none of us hope for it is with a
song sense of duty that I rise today in
support of impeachment a sad day for
America I'm not gleeful for today no
they're not gleeful but they're not
solemn or prayerful either by the way
they were reportedly taking selfies on
the House floor tonight for a few months
though they were ecstatic when they
thought a whistleblower was going to
deliver a victory next November a
victory they knew was going to be
difficult amidst the roaring economy
they needed something to help him but
then the impeachment polls started to
turn not one or two but several showing
that Americans aren't buying their
evidence free hyperbole on Ukraine after
countless hours oh my gosh - so tedious
these speeches and panels of liberal
academics and hearsay witnesses and
bitter foreign service officers
fewer Americans not more believe that
Donald Trump committed an impeachable
offense Americans are pretty smart
aren't they they can spot a sham when
they see one
the same Democrats by the way who
vehemently opposed impeaching Clinton in
the 1990s because the crimes weren't
serious enough they now want Trump
removed from office for committing no
crime at all repeating a lie over and
over again shift thought would be enough
to win over America that's how little he
thinks of your intelligence there was a
blizzard of lies flying around the house
chamber today so we're gonna focus
tonight I'm just the important ones lie
number one the facts are settled
the uncontested evidence shows Donald
Trump violated his oath of office the
facts are not in dispute
the facts are black and white the
evidence is undisputed not a single fact
in this case if seriously in dispute
this is ludicrous on its face Jim Jordan
told the story well early this evening
Democrats forgot two key things forgot
about the facts and they forgot about
fairness no quid pro quo two guys on the
call who repeatedly said there was no
pressure most importantly Ukraine took
no action no announcement of
investigation to get the aid released
but Democrats don't care they don't care
about the facts and they sure don't care
about the process in other words
sois well is unwell if he thinks the
evidence is undisputed line number two
this has been an open aboveboard and
totally fair process members of both
parties have been involved at every
stage of the in the depositions we
conducted an intelligence committee over
a hundred members were able to
participate the president was given the
opportunity to come and testify before
the Judiciary Committee to send this
council to question witnesses he
declined to do so okay any lawyer who
would have advised Trump to appear
before ship or Nadler Star Chamber
should be disbarred again Jordan nailed
it no subpoena powerful Republicans no
Republican witnesses during the
depositions Republicans were prevented
from getting all their questions
answered but Democrats got every one of
their questions and then of course the
whistleblower the anonymous
whistleblower with no first-hand
knowledge bias against the president who
worked for Joe Biden was never compelled
to testify the guy who started it all
we almost didn't recognize him because
he had the jacket on line number three
Trump used Ukrainian aid for political
leverage he leveraged critically needed
congressionally approved military aid to
Ukraine in order to coerce a fraudulent
investigation into a potential political
opponent
military aid provided to fight the
Russians as leverage solely to benefit
his own political campaign George
Washington would be astonished George
Washington Democrats aren't just
originalist now suddenly their
clairvoyance - here are the facts
Ukraine's military aid was delayed a
mere 55 days and it was all within
reasonable bounds it was released within
the time frame that's established by
Congress Ukraine didn't have to announce
investigations into the Biden's or the
2016 election or take any other actions
it's ridiculous line number four Trump
actively sought for an election meddling
the president actively sought for an
election interference to benefit himself
the integrity of the 2020 election
remains at risk Donald J Trump's
sacrificed our national security in an
effort to cheat in the next election if
you think our national security is
intimately connected with Ukraine then
we got to go back to school okay it's
ridiculous first of all we have the
transcript of Trump's call with zalenski
we know he never once mentions the 2020
election and then there's a small matter
of that stumbling bumbling Joe Biden the
fact that he hasn't won his party's
nomination yet he isn't Trump's ultimate
rival the Biden's like the Clintons
brought this problem on themselves by
ignoring obvious conflicts of interest
barista hunter and accepting large sums
of money when they shouldn't have so I'm
glad the president wants answers about
all of that Joe Biden doesn't get a free
pass from scrutiny because he's running
for president that's absurd line number
five no one is above the law I know the
president said that he can get away with
anything he wants to no he cannot
because no one is above the law if you
live on 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue you are
not above the law
least he knows the address of the White
House wait a second Democrats don't
believe that for a second
by their own conduct and pas
sieze from the way they shielded the
clintons
to the way they currently shield the
Biden's they don't even want those
questions asked and of course to the way
they prop up and coddle illegal
immigrants who are so far out of the
shadows at this point that they lined up
block by block by block to wait for
driver's licenses in New York this week
line number six trump is obstructing
Congress he tried to cover up his
scandalous behavior and he obstructed
the investigation he obstructed Congress
every step of the way in an effort to
cover it all up instead he's blocked
numerous witnesses from testifying about
his actions president Trump's actions
are even worse than Nixon's talk about
zero credibility on New York must be so
proud
Democrats want you to believe that the
president challenging subpoenas in court
or asserting executive privilege is an
impeachable offense well guess what as
Alan Dershowitz has said so many times
on this show
that would have Visser eight executive
privilege and destroy our separation of
powers in a little matter of the
Democrats they didn't go to court if
they wanted to show obstruction they
needed to file an emergency petition in
court hmm so why didn't they
and that's the angle